soldiers arrive in San Ignacio to help
combat wildfires Bolivia's famous
colonial jewel settled by Jesuit
missionaries in the late 1600s is been
converted into an Operations Center for
the firefighting effort night and day
the wildfires are spreading out of
control fanned by strong winds a
prolonged drought and extremely high
temperatures we feel sad to see how the
animals in the forest are burning but we
are proud to be able to help these
soldiers are going off again to fight
the fires but as you can see they're not
very well equipped they don't look like
firemen they don't have the equipment of
firemen their boots have rubber soles
that can easily melt in the flames and
in the intense heat and they also don't
have the proper masks to protect them
from vi smoke and from smoke inhalation
thousands of young volunteers are
joining them like acento Rivera from
Ecuador never fought fires before but we
will use the nerves of steel and
adrenaline to do it this fire isn't just
the Bolivian problem it's all of ours
because the tropical forest is
fundamental for our survival
this part of Eastern Bolivia is cattle
country nearly two months ago the
government signed a decree authorizing
ranchers to expand the grazing frontier
using fire to clear the tropical forests
cattle is good business says the mayor
the President signed the decree in the
presence of the leaders of the cattle
ranchers they don't take into account
the weather or the fact that a drought
makes it very dangerous to clear the
land with fire they don't care and this
is the result
the decree hasn't been rescinded despite
more than 1.5 million hectares Bolivia's
Amazon and Chiquita no tropical forests
destroyed so far by fire volunteers pray
for God to send them rain and for a time
it seems their prayers are answered the
mare is jubilant the light shower is
insufficient to stop the catastrophe but
given the circumstances people here
believe every drop counts
Lucia Neumann San Ignacio Bolivia